Avec nous,
Dr Mario Leone, professeur
à la Faculté de médecine
et des sciences dededededededed.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.ncncncncncncncncncncn.
Vous avez vu les chiffres, vous
Le recul est quand même vraiment
y a 35 ans?
- Absolument.
Pour nous, ce qu'on a constaté,
dont les chiffres ont été
reportage que vous avez
présenté. Bon,
cardiovasculaire elle-même,
c'est-à-dire unité métabolique
qui est interprétée par le VO2
max, une chute, c'est quand
significatif.
Et ce qui est encore un pe
dérangeant, c'est la chute de 3r
de la capacité fonctionnelle des
gens, c'est-à-dire la capacité
soutenir, tel qu'indarararar le
nombre de paliers complétés par.
- Quand vous avez commencé à
travailler làesesesesesesesesese
vous vous attendiez à ce qu'il y
ait une déioioioion aussi grande
de la santé cardiovasculaire des
jeunes
- Bien, de façon anecdotique
en
sont proches des jeunes, enysyse
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui et ceqr
carrière.
On s'attendait à ça.
On voit aussi qu'il y a plus
d'obésité, plus d'embonpoint.
pas une bonne performance au
niveau cardiovasculaire. Ce qui
nous a surpris, celles en
pleurs. Une donnée qui nous a
particulièrement frappé, qui est
particulièrement frappante :
quand regarde au niveau du seuil
pour les éventuels problèmes,
pour les garçons parl,l,l,l,l,l,
et les filles 37 ml.
On constate qu'euuuuuu
importe le groupe d'âges, de six
à 17 ans, tout le monde était
largemenrororororororororororore
éventuellement contre les
troubles que je viens de
mentionner.'o'o'o'o'o'o'o'o'o'o,
58 % des garçons et 70 % desllln
deçà de cette valeur seuil, ce
qui les expose à des problèmes
- On montre les chiffres. Ça,
c'est important. Vous dites à
l'époque, oui il y en avait un
peu moins en forme, des
mais personne, ou à peu près
dangereux qui peut avoir des
conséquences plus tard, des
maladies cardiovasculaires, etc.
Et aujourdueueueueueueueueueueu%
des filles. C'est ça la lumière
rouge de?papapapapapapapapapapai
est inquiétant, c'est ça.
d d d d d d d dire, c'est
que des lâches de 17 ans, etmemn
atteint le seuil de 50 % et plus
élevés de signes inquiétants des
lâches de cinq ans. Ça veut dire
plus que la moitié des jeunes
qui actuellement sont dans une
situation où il s'expose à un
risque qui va aller en
problèmes comme le diabète,
obésité, et bon, chez ce
avoir des codes d'hypertension
artérielle.
- Mario Leone, j
à la ministre
qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
trouver un moment.pepepepepepep,
et corrigez-moi si je me trompe,
ndndndndndndndndndnd une heure,
mais devrait éducation physique
par jour. Pas juste... Il faut s
augmentent leur capacité
justement pulmonaire et.........
il y a beaucoup d'études quintns
périodes d'éducation physique
sont plus nombreuses et aussi en
parle d'une heure,
au moins trois à quatre fois par
On constate que ça a des effets
excessivement bénéfiques sur
leur état de santé général, mais
aussi évidemment sur leur
Mais aussi, ça écarte les
possibilité de développer des
problèmes, parce que leur niveau
de forme est plu
maladies, évidemment, moins de
fatigue, parce
forme, et tout ce qui découle de
cela.
Donc c'e d d d d d d d d d d d s
mesures pour corriger cela.
vous avez comparé les données dt
intuitivement ou vous avez vu
des données pour d'autres
endroits sur la planète? Est-cùu
les résultats sont plus
positifs? Est-ce qu'on a ces
- En fait, dans les pays
industrialisés, qui sont à peu
vit ici au Québec, au Canada,c'z
généralisée. On constate
depuis 20,30, 40 ans, que c'es
beaucoup avec les augmentations
d'utilisation de équipements
électroniques, chose qui
n'existait à peu près pas dans
les années 80.
Donc en fait, le principal
problème, c'est le temps que les
jeunes mettaient
80 dans les activités qui
demandaient d'être actif
physiq
par des comportements très
passifs, donc, ou qu'on passe
be s s s s s s s s s s s s s sur
les jeux vidéo, à jouer avec les
tablettes. C'est un problème
fondamental.
Vous savez, les jeunes de 1980,
au niveau cardiovasculaire, il
n'y a pas eu de mutation
génétique qui, tout d'un coup, n
coeur plus petit et moins de
musc. C'est les comportementsgée
nouvelle c'est que ces
réversibles, mais il faut mettre
des mesures en place.
On peut s'inspirer de ce quelels
années 80 et dire :
si on réussit à reproduire cela
avec les contraintes des années
2020, mais d'essayer de se
rapprocher de cela, on
améliorerait sensiblement
les résultats qu'on voit
actuellement.
- Très clair. Merci beaucou